hey on today's show we're going to talk
to a young woman whose mom
tragically passed away when she was
young and as she
approaches her mom's age she's starting
to become more anxious and more anxious
we're going to talk to a great dad whose
wife had an affair and is not interested
in keeping the marriage going and he
wants to know what to do next
we're going to talk to a awesome young
woman who is recovering from a rough
bout of covid
who just wants to know how can i turn my
anxiety alarms off and what can i do
next
stay tuned
hey what's up what's up this is delony
with the dr
john delony show taking your calls about
your life
your relationships schools
uh marriages um parents
your mental health your depression your
anxiety your adhd your bipolar disorder
how are you gonna love better how you
are gonna deal with people you are
frustrated with
on this show we talk about all of it and
it's your calls
it's your emails it's your notes and
here's the thing i'm not immune to this
i am walking alongside you man
so whatever's going on in your life
whatever's going on in your heart in
your mind in your home
in your schools in your neighborhood in
your country
geez louise give me a shout at
1-844-693-3291 that's 1-844-693-3291
or you can go to johndaloni.com show and
you fill out the form it goes right to
kelly
and that she will go through it and see
if you are a great fit for the show
so we got a new segment today and it's a
one-time segment
just for today and it's where i tell you
that i did something that i got on this
show and said never ever do
and here's the consequences so if you're
watching this on
on the youtubes that's one of those
internet tv shows that people with
camcorders can now make
um you can see i've got these permanent
scars on my arm
all up and down my arm here you may be
blinded by my incredible tan if you're
watching this but
beneath that glare that's that's coming
off my skin
is forever scars down my arm and here's
why
um during christmas break me and my son
were clearing some brush
out at the house that sounds way cooler
than it really is
in your mind i know you immediately
thought i had like this red filson
outfit on and a matching carhartt jacket
and a cool hat
i didn't i would look like i look like
an idiot my son looks good
and we're clearing brush cutting down
just
junk and shenanigans and i got covered
up in poison ivy
which is not a thing in january except
in the south that super is and so i'm
covered up in poison ivy
and what did i do you know i did
i asked my wife hey um i've had this
before here's what i did and she's like
yeah that's a good idea
which is to get some like calamine
lotion put it on there
and just ride it out but i did something
even better
i did something that i got on this
podcast and said i hate it when people
do this
and i thought you know i hate it so much
i think i'm gonna do it
i got on the internets and looked up
remedies for poison ivy and then i ended
up
with oh i wonder with i can use
all of these voodoo magic dragon
encrusted
um essential oils which
by the way can cure cancer it solves
math problems
it can bring um fairy dust into
i it can do anything it's actually
bringing the
polar ice caps are re-freezing due to
essential oils those things can do
anything
and i thought man i bet if i google
essential oils and
poison ivy so what i did and you
essential oil wizards out there are
going to grown at this
but i covered myself day after day
with straight oregano oil because
oregano oil will solve everything and
evidently
in the uh essential oil world oregano
oil is basically turpentine it's
gasoline
and i poured it on my flesh and then
christmas night or christmas eve night
which i spent in er by the way and i
don't even go to the doctor i'm in
doctor years
i did that night because i was taking a
shower in big
chunks of my body started coming out it
was coming off
as i was showering and i remember
thinking
oh that doesn't look good and so i got a
shower and i showed my wife and i said
hey
i know i'm prone to drama she knew what
she married we did it a long time
but i said i'm gonna show you this it
doesn't look great and i showed it to
her and she without even
breaking she said we're going to the
hospital right now and i was like it's
not and it was bleeding all day
but i mean chunks not just skin was
coming off parts of my body were coming
off
so i went to a rural er in the middle of
the night and to his
credit the doctor walked in and he goes
all right i just want to be i want to be
honest with you guys
um it is christmas eve
and i'm in a rural er i just want you to
know what kind of doctor i probably
am and we all had a good laugh about it
and
then i had to go back with the healing
but i'm gonna be scared for the rest of
my life
moral of that story number one this is
my confession
i did what i said don't do don't go on
the internet and look for
health advice i know it's so cool to be
like oh you know what they're so smart
there and edgy and cool and if you just
eat pork rinds and frogs you're gonna
get ripped
stupid inner it's dumb it's dumb talk to
doctors or people with degrees who know
what they're talking about when it comes
to medical advice
not voodoo people who are gonna
tell you to put essential oils all over
your body
and number two if you do something that
you tell everybody not to do you've got
to be
woman enough or man enough to admit it
so this is me telling you i'm an idiot
and i did what i said i wasn't going to
do don't put oregano oil
on skin burns because evidently chunks
of your body will fall off
all right that's it that's my um that's
my usher moment of the day
we're gonna go straight to the calls
we're not going straight to the calls
we're going to the calls after i just
ran my mouth for five minutes
let's go to stephanie in pine bluff
arkansas
stephanie what's going hey you're a pine
bluff you know about poison ivy right
i do i've had it before did you douse
yourself in essential oils and have to
go to the er
no i did have to go to the doctor and
calamine lotion
all of that i know in bed for a few days
see you're my stephanie we are brother
and sister
you just made my heart feel good if
you're from canada or the northeast and
you're like what's what's poison ivy
hmm on you okay stephanie what's up how
can i help
okay so when i was 12 years old my mom
passed away
of colon cancer oh man how old are you
now
i'm 33 now okay and she was 41 when she
passed
oh that sucks i'm sorry stephanie yeah
thank you thank you um so from the date
of her diagnosis to the date of her
death was only 16 days
we
and it was just really fast and very
shocking to
everybody um but i'm 33 now and i'm
married and i have two kids
and life is good but the closer
that i get to 41 i just dread it
and i'm nervous i'm anxious i know i
have eight more years but
i i dread 41.
yeah i have like a mental block about it
and just want to know how
maybe i could work through that for
myself and for my family
yeah so how old are your kids i have a
six-year-old
daughter and a three-year-old little boy
okay so
as much as you turning 41 keep an eye
out for
the older that your kids get yeah
um because you've got a 12 year old girl
in there that is just hunkered down
holding the fort down right
right yeah all right so um tell me about
your mom
she's awesome um we were
i can hear you smiling through the phone
by the way
tell me about her yeah she was awesome
she was
a wonderful mom i mean she up till
when she got sick she still did my hair
every day we picked my clothes out
every day we went to the grocery store
together every week
helped her cook most nights
every weekend we're in the kitchen you
know making desserts and her famous
chocolate cake and
she was just very loving lots of
physical touch
and she was just like a perfect mom huh
yeah she was awesome oh man so tell me
about your dad
and he's he's great too he really
stepped up when
she passed away and he never dated he
never remarried he still wears his
wedding band
to this wow yeah i mean he's
he committed his life to my older
brother and myself
once she passed away and he was already
committed but even more so
um he just stepped in the gaps and tried
to be mom and dad
yeah so what is this
this dread what does it feel like i
don't want to
leave my family like she left us
i know the hole that was left after she
passed away
and i dread that for my husband and for
my kids because that hurt is still there
of course yeah yeah um when you
you just gave me a thought how does it
feel
you're driving down the street and you
are
you know a few you're getting closer
right to that 41
and you feel it what does it feel like
it's just hit in my stomach yeah that
gets that warmth in your stomach
yeah yeah and then tell me the thoughts
that are going through your head
oh gosh just that that i just don't want
to leave
i don't want to leave them because i
love the life that we're building
of course yeah i don't want them to feel
the hurt
that i felt and that my dad felt and
that
my brother felt i don't want my family
to feel that how did you grieve her loss
when you i mean
and again even if you knew it was coming
you can't there there is no
um there is no process for a 12 year old
right
especially with a wonderful loving mom
that was plugged in and all of a sudden
is just
vanishes um how did you grieve that loss
how have you grieved it over the years
um i was very angry at first of course i
became
extremely independent because she did so
much for me
i became independent and i'm still very
independent to this day
but um i feel like i grieved it well i
never did counseling even though my dad
kind of
offered it to me and i was like oh no
that's not for me
looking back i probably should have but
you know
okay that's i'm gonna answer you there
but i'm also going to speak to everybody
there's this idea that every time
there's a tragedy everyone's got to run
to a counselor
and one of the one of the
um trauma counseling phrases that we
live by
is most people are okay most of the time
that doesn't mean that they're going to
be perfect they're not going to have
permanent scars
obviously you will forever this is an
extraordinary woman that just got
ganged from you right the cosmos just
took her from you um
but that doesn't mean you have to go run
spend the next five years with a
therapist right so
um if you felt great and you still feel
strong there
good for you okay i want you to feel
like you screwed something up and should
have done something that now is setting
you on a poor trajectory somewhere right
yeah um so you didn't go see a counselor
you
had friends family community around you
oh yes
lots of my best friends their mothers
stepped up and
helped me get through the teenage years
and yeah i really jumped into
church and had a great community of
people around me
and still do yeah so here's
you're in a pretty unique spot so have
you ever heard of aces
uh adverse childhood experiences no um
if you haven't there's um it's a
remarkable
it's basically a new direction that just
talks about childhood trauma can set us
up down the road for
increases in things that we would never
expect like stroke and cancer and heart
disease and obesity things like that
that up until just recently we haven't
connected
we've been chasing biological interest
we never thought that the inflammation
spun out from those traumas especially
cumulative traumas
can can send us down these these hard
hard health paths right
and one of the cornerstones of this
research is that one of the most
important things that can help a kid
who's experienced a robust dark trauma
like you did
is a buffering adult
people community that step in those gaps
that
are there for kids and
it can't take the hurt away nothing will
take that hurt away
but will help a kid get to the next day
into the next day into the next day
and they don't lose that ability to
learn how to connect
and so you know this but
wow i just want to call it out what an
absolute gift your old man was
what a gift to those men and women who
stepped in the gap and the teachers and
the coaches
and the just the folks who probably
showed up with meals all through your
childhood
and um it may have been uh it may have
been a blessing but you didn't have to
deal with also the hard stuff of getting
to know a stepmom
and watching your dad fall in love with
somebody you didn't experience that
um and that's not always a bad thing
something sometimes that's a wonderful
thing but
wow what a what a what a a great moment
that brings us to right now okay a great
a great life that brings us to right now
here's what your brain is doing it is
just scanning the environment
for ways and things that you are going
to be taking from your family
right you get that pain it is not going
to it does not want you
you to be the person who inflicts that
pain on the people around you
do you go to the doctor regularly now
that you know when you have colon cancer
obviously every time you ever go to the
doctor they ask you about it um
have you been screened are you healthy
you good
yes i've been screened i've had a
colonoscopy i had that
last year and i'll have another one
every other year at this point
um yeah i've had
genetic testing to see if i have any
cancer genes
um because my grandboth of my
grandmothers had cancer as well
and i don't carry any cancer
genes right now of course unless i get
something you know from the environment
so so here's the magic stephanie
you're not gonna get cancer at 41.
yeah you're not um does that mean you're
bulletproof
no does that mean a bus may not come
along
no you're right right does that mean
that a meteorite might fall on
no but you you're not gonna get cancer
and i'm telling you that out loud for
this because our trauma alarms our
anxiety alarms don't always follow
math right they don't always follow
facts and so what i want you to commit
to over the next
five to six years is two things number
one
you have a ringside seat to the value of
every day
that most of us waltzing through life
don't have
and sometimes that um insight can be
seen as a burden
or you can work really hard to
acknowledge it as the gift that it is
and you go to sleep tired every day
because you suck the life out of that
day
right yeah and so i want you to it
sounds like you're on that trajectory
you got a beautiful family
you've got people who love and care
about you and you are so
thoughtful about the people around you
not even you're not even telling me
i'm scared i'm gonna die that's not your
words your words are i'm scared the
people that i love are going to be hurt
you are a special rare air woman
stephanie and they need to
they need to keep your dna and replicate
you because we need more of you in this
world
but number one continue on that checking
every day for how can i drain this day
for the joy drain this day for the
experiences and the adventures and drain
every drop of love and connection i can
out of that day
right remember number two obviously keep
yourself well and i said i had two
things i got three
obviously do the things you need to do
to keep yourself well it's
man i have talked to so so so many
people over the years
who have somebody who's got heart
disease in their family or cancer or
anxiety or depression and their response
is to bury their head
or to drink it away or to sleep with
somebody else and somebody else and
somebody else and somebody else in
somebody else away right
to do anything to numb it and you're not
you're facing that demon head on you're
getting colonoscopies every year which
are just a
a barrel it's a circus right everyone
loves a colonoscopy every other year
right
um and so you're facing it head-on
you're a true
true gangster and the third thing
is this when those thoughts start
spinning i want you to speak
out loud affirmatively
no thank you i'm healthy and i'm gonna
be here when i'm 41.
okay and what i want you to start doing
is speaking out loud and people can
think you're nuts now don't do it in a
target they'll call somebody
but when you're driving right or you're
laying in bed and you just have had an
extraordinary day with your kids and
your husband
and your stomach starts getting that
warmth like oh what if i'm not here
that's when i want you to whisper to
yourself
no i'm not going to get cancer i want
you to smile big
and i want you to take a big deep breath
i'm not
i'm not going to get cancer because you
know that's the truth and if the
thoughts start spinning
and they come quicker and more i want
you to step up uh get out a piece of
paper and write them down
and i want you to demand evidence from
those thoughts am i going to get colon
cancer at 41 and leave my family
no did the unthinkable happen to me as a
12 year old girl yeah it
sucks am i going to continue continue to
love these crazy people
because the end of the road is the same
for all of us right for you it's going
to be 94
but for all of us we're the same road
and so man we're going to just continue
we're going to drain life of all of its
adventures in joy
but i want you to write those thoughts
down when they become heavy heavy and
heavy
and i want you to make sure you commit
to staying vulnerable with people
staying open with people
my guess is the alarms will get louder
the closer you get to 41.
the closer your daughter and or your son
gets to
12 it's gonna get louder and louder
and if it gets loud to where you can't
function to where when your kid goes to
school you find yourself
where you're just you're crying where
you find yourself
being unreasonably over the top like you
can't go outside because i don't want
you when you have those moments or every
headache you think oh this is it and
your heart starts racing you go straight
to the internets
don't do that by the way that's when you
may need to go step in
and see somebody now you didn't need to
see someone as a counselor you had great
buffering adults maybe now that you're
older
and you're heading into a season you're
going to have to have a season of
practice to learn some adult skills
right some adult um control over your
thoughts and actions and that's just a
skill to practice that's totally normal
we should all be doing that
and you've got some extra special
reasons but my guess is
you're gonna have those fleeting moments
those heavy moments but you're well
stephanie and you're you're not broken
you're not sad if your
body and your brain remembers a trauma
that heavy
that means you're normal that means your
body's working great
that means you're still a great mom and
a great wife to your husband
that means everything's plugging along
that means you're just not gonna forget
that wonderful wonderful woman she's
just not gonna evaporate into the mist
right um thank you so so much for that
call stephanie
as you get closer if you you know
there's there's the chance that dave
fires me dave ramsey fires me the next
four five years
strong to quite strong let's be honest
i'm not super good at this show but if
we're both still around when you turn 41
please call me back because i would love
to hear how you are navigating that
i know you're gonna be doing it well and
the people around you are gonna be
loving you loving you loving you
man the world needs more stephanie's all
right let's go to jeremiah in los
angeles california what's up brother
jeremiah how are you doing
hey dr john how you doing sir i'm doing
all right brother how are we doing
oh you know it's one of those days it's
a good day today so you know it's all i
can say about that
that sounds ominous man but that could
mean a lot of things somebody
calling from los angeles so what's going
on how can i help
so uh i'll just get straight to the
point i've been with my wife for 14
years
12 married um found out last year that
she was kind of having an affair with
somebody at
our local gym here hey let me can i stop
can i stop you right there
yeah sure what does kind of having an
affair mean
well i guess uh to me i mean uh i'm i'm
thinking of it
as like a physical or uh more of a uh
emotional than a physical so i just say
kinda
okay don't say if there was a violation
of y'all's boundaries don't say kind of
let's just call it what it is okay
yeah yes okay she has she was having an
affair
okay with a with a guy at the gym and uh
it was probably
you know going on for about six months i
kind of had an incling to it
you know before before i found out
officially but
i mean it was just kind of in the back
of my head um
but officially found out last year for
sure that it was going on and so it's
been a year since then
when i found out and just things right
now are rocky
um you know we're we're trying to work
it out well i guess i'm trying to work
it out but
really it just seems like a one-way
street with us
you know i'm trying trying everything
here and then
you know i've never reached out to
anybody else besides you know my brother
family stuff like that but uh you know i
saw your program
on youtube and you know i was listening
to it i was like you know what i'm going
to reach out to dr john
and that's where that's where we're at i
appreciate your trust brother
um and it's just important to
acknowledge i know we hear about this
all the time all the time all the time
but this sucks man i'm sorry this
happened to you man
now thank you appreciate it um so
when you and your wife sat down and
talked about this i don't know if you
sell text messages or you saw she was
sending him photos or something like
that
you find out then you sit down and have
the conversation what was the
conversation like
so conversation was well i i found out
at work um
you know with the text messages actually
from the the guy's wife that she was
seeing um so i got the text messages i
i'm thinking in the back of my head like
no this is this is fake you know i
didn't know the number
i'm just putting it put everything
behind me i'm like nah that's not real
and then they sent the text messages
back and forth and i'm just like oh my
gosh my world just
crashed yeah dude so you talked to your
wife you talked to your wife how does
that go man
yeah your heart's broken you don't even
know what dad is right you're not eating
yeah how'd that conversation go um
for the most part uh i mean i came home
early that day and i
you know i took her by the hand and my
daughter was in the room so i said you
know let's go to the back i got to ask
you something and
you know i was real level-headed cool i
wasn't you know angry or anything i just
i wanted to just
you know hear it from her like is this
for real like i mean i showed her the
text messages and everything and
you know like i told you before i kind
of had an inkling so when i saw those i
just was like
oh my god oh my goodness you know like i
can't believe this right now
yeah so i mean um you know she was very
dismissive about it just like oh no he's
just a friend
you know uh and then after we talked
about a little more it's like other
things start coming out like oh he's my
best friend
i can talk to him a lot and mind you
he's a
stay-at-home dad himself and she's a
stay-at-home mom
which she has been for the last 10 years
so um
you know i i don't know i just was i
just was in shock dr
john yeah yeah yeah rightfully so
my heart was in a thousand pieces i'm
over there trying to pick it up trying
to put it back together and
that's what i feel like i've been doing
the last year and it just doesn't seem
like it's going anywhere
so her first response was denial in a
lie when did she circle up and say
finally admit like yeah
i've been seeing this dude um
i mean i would say probably like a
couple weeks after we had you know we
were having conversations all the time
about it
yeah and you know just you know she just
finally said like one day like you know
like like
he's my best friend like i i just want
to see him all the time and
it just was that was another killer it's
like how do you say that this guy's your
best friend when i'm your husband and
we're supposed to be best friends you
know we're supposed to be the ones
talking all the time
were you all having were you was this a
total shock to you or y'all having
problems in your marriage have you all
talked about being distant
in the past no no that's that was
another thing is like we we i always
felt like our relationship was very
close
you know we're you know we're always
we're always honest with each other
we're always talking to each other
and then um you know for this to come
about it just was like i said a total
shocker i just couldn't
i'm just going to wrap my head around it
honestly yeah man i'm sorry
so so why do you want to stay in this
relationship man
because i love her i mean she's the love
of my life i've been with her for 14
years
we have two beautiful girls together um
and we
we both come from broken marriages yeah
my mom and dad got
divorced when i was in my in it when i
was 18
and she didn't have her dad you know
pretty much most of her life so
um and he still isn't a part of her life
to this day
so when you say she's not invested she
has no interest in and staying
she telling you i want to be divorced um
she's she's brought it up a couple times
but it's never the trigger's never been
pulled on it she's
she's talked about separating you know i
just don't i just don't feel the same
way about you
you know i i feel like we're on two
separate paths and it's like
you know i've always been on the same
path doctor john i work you know all the
time to provide
for the family you know that's my role
as a man i feel like you know i came
from that type of background
and you know i don't know if it's some
type of resentment she holds towards me
because i get to leave every day and
leave her with the kids
or what what it is i i i i'm gonna tell
you this jeremiah you're gonna make
yourself
stone insane trying to get inside her
head
and figure out why she's thinking the
way she's thinking
right okay and when we get hurt or we
get scared or we get
out of control it's that's a temptation
man it's getting uh
i know why they did that because of x
man you're going to make yourself nuts
you know what i mean and there's
probably a thousand different things
and what i'll tell you is it's a fool's
errand you're never gonna fully get
there
and you're just gonna you're gonna drive
yourself mad so
here's the ah man i i
yeah i'm going to here's the thing you
can't change her mind
right she's an adult and she's going to
have to make that decision
um what this tension is and what this
back and forth
is and what this uh yeah i don't know
on her end and um the tension you feel
in your own house walking around
eggshells in your own house and it my
guess is it probably vacillates between
this is my damn house i'm gonna be who i
wanna be
and then also you're on exhales because
you want to make her mad and then you're
starting to feel yourself
lose it right yeah exactly um
and then you talk to yourself you have
these pep talks on the way home your
heart rate gets up you get kind of fired
up about it
and then that the next day you're gonna
bring flowers and
you're just going to start spinning
yourself out so
there's the important part of the just
y'all being adults
right and i know i'm talking this is a
pot talking to kettle here
but two adults have got to get in a room
and have this conversation
but right there's a reason underneath
that
well you need to have this conversation
because i need to have this conversation
right you just need to make some
decisions
but i'm going to tell you right now you
are not passively
influencing your daughters you are
affirmatively hurting them
okay okay they are absorbing this
tension
they are absorbing your back and forth
your wife's indifference whatever she's
saying about you when you're not there
her staring at her phone all day while
they're in her presence or not
all of that stuff they're absorbing and
here's the deal brother
they are in their little minds how old
are they
uh 10 and six oh gosh yeah and they're
ten and six-year-old that's
about the age of my kids every every
interaction with their parents every bit
of tension they are absorbing as their
fault and they're gonna spend their life
trying to fix it
um not a good thing no
it's not all of that tension all of that
ambiguity frustration they absorb
and sometimes kids try to solve that
through being perfect
sometimes kids solve that through
addiction they solve that through one
relationship after another after another
they solve that through the the they
go on religious walkabouts whatever that
may be but they spend their life chasing
that down
very similar situation you find yourself
in right
yeah and definitely all that to say is
this you have
got to have a hard conversation
in a in a respectful kind dignified way
because there is a chance that your wife
is a terrible terrible
wife and an extraordinary mom she might
be a great mom to these girls
she might does she love those kids oh
yeah she does she she's a great mother
i'll i'll never
never take that away from her she's the
she's the best mom because
well just like i said to the first color
man we need more guys like you in the
world i
appreciate your heart here my guess is
this is probably a long time coming
and whether you missed it or whether
your wife was highly deceptive
usually it's a it's a it's both and
something sneaks up on people or
something doesn't sneak up on people
whatever happens to me i need you to go
to your wife
and say listen for the sake of our
daughters they're absorbing this
this is real writing in their hearts
what relationships look like what
relationships
feel like and they are taking all of
this tension on their hearts
we can't do that to our daughters we've
got to make some decisions in this house
and i love you i want to be your husband
i'll go to the ends of the earth to
figure out how to make this work
um please don't give up on us let's go
get a
marriage therapist let's go get all
let's go all in right
and and let her make a decision
yeah and i know that's a scary thing
because there's a reality that she's
going to say i'm opting for not you
and that's very scary right it is
very yeah that's heartbreaking that's uh
um yeah that's all in man
and it sounds like she
does she care about you she says she
does
okay obviously i mean behavior i mean
the
the affair nonetheless is she still in
touch with this dude are they still
interacting talking all the time
no they're not talking at all actually
the day after i found out we went
and changed her phone number and uh and
all that kind of stuff so
she said she hasn't been in contact with
them at all um
since then um also too if i could just
mention it uh like with
our uh our sleeping arrangements and
stuff she's out on the couch
okay i'm in the bed by myself um you
know intimacy is that
out of nothing we're not none of that's
going on
when's the last time y'all when's the
last time you all slept together
um like slept together or sexually
sexually yeah
um it's probably been about like a month
and a week
okay something like that okay um
when's the last time you sat down and
said we just need to have a
grown-up intimate direct conversation
with one another
just that just actually the other day
honestly how'd it go
um you know it went better than i
thought okay um
i i sat down i talked to her i let her
know that i was
i i was in contact with you guys with
your show sure and i let her know that
wednesday i'm i'm gonna be talking to
you know uh dr john um he's a counselor
stuff like that so i let her know that
i'm reaching out there
to to try and make this work sure have
you all gone to gone to see a marriage
therapist have you all gone
she won't go no she won't go we've had
that conversation she's like well what
are they gonna tell us and i was like
well they'll tell us what we need to do
yeah you know and it's like that's why i
was saying it's like a one-way street
with this relationship it seems like
right now it's like i want to reach out
i want to save it
but it just doesn't seem like she
doesn't want that she doesn't want to
save it
does she want you to be the bad guy here
does she want you to be the guy that
breaks it off why what's keeping her
from walking out the door
that's what i'm saying i don't know and
i think that's what she wants is for me
to make the decision i said you know
what no this is your decision
i am not making the decision because i
don't want to make that decision i don't
want to leave the relationship i want to
be with you i love you
yeah you know and and i don't know
i i think she's waiting for that that's
maybe that's why she's
you know not we're not sexually active
anymore maybe she's holding out on me
for that reason i don't i have no idea
uh see again don't get in her head man
okay right make yourself bananas
um there's a thousand different reasons
why intimacy happens and doesn't happen
and all that
yeah um i'd love to talk to her if
she'll call the show i'd love to love to
talk to her to get her
what's going on in her heart and mind if
she would um but all
to say is this if she won't have
an adult conversation and she did if she
won't make an adult decision
yeah for you for herself
you'll have to make some decisions for
your daughters okay yeah
sooner rather than later and my hope
hope hope i
again man i'm the most naively
optimistic guy on the planet and i'm not
naive about it i just i've seen people
come back from so many different brinks
come over so many obstacles because they
fight and they claw and they say
i'm not giving up on this thing i
thought this marriage was an
ash and we're gonna we're gonna redraw
we're gonna rebuild it and we're gonna
create something better and new
and different it's not gonna be the old
thing that we just reconstruct we're
gonna do something remarkable
i've seen it over and over and over i've
had moments in my marriage dude that i
was like oh man things going down it's
going down it's going down
yeah we hung on and we rebuilt something
new we're still rebuilding something new
and i think every marriage is
continually rebuilding and rebuilding
and adding and growing
i i've got high hopes for you man but i
do as well but my house are very high
she's got to um she's y'all got to make
a decision
sooner rather than later for those girls
um so here's my challenge
to you do what i just said sit down and
have that hard conversation
on behalf of your daughters on behalf of
you on behalf of her she's killing
herself man
she's got to make a decision and you can
let her know equivocally i will not end
this marriage
period and but we've got to fix this i
want you back
in sleep in bed with me i want you to
we go to marriage counselor you know
what they're going to give you tools
they're going to help you have hard
conversations with one another tell the
truth with one another
be open you may hear things about i
promise you will hear things about you
over the last decade
that you don't like that you didn't even
know you were doing but you're gonna
hear a man
that's what a marriage counselor will do
to give her a place to be fully honest
and open with you
um and there there'll be a referee there
but also be someone who's gonna teach
you a teacher is gonna give you guys
some tools you can work on and rebuild
this thing from the floor up
but those little girls are hanging in
the balance man they're hanging in that
tension and they're absorbing every
second of it man
so the last thing is man i'd love her to
call the show we will
i will move her to the front of the line
if she'll call the show and um
or shoot me an email i'll go to
johndaloney.comshow
let her know that she's jeremiah's wife
and we'll move to the front show i'd
love to hear her perspective on this
she's probably not going to but
um i'd love to hear from her but man
we're thinking about you
and let me know how that conversation
goes let me know what that final
decision is shoot me a note back
and we'll let the listeners know how
things played out
don't give in to despair jeremiah don't
give
in to treating her less than
with dignity and respect because at the
end of the day that's just going to
bring you
down and drown you so um you've it
sounds like you've taken the high road
on this thing continue to even if you
get the worst of worst news that she's
moving out and the things over
continue to think about those girls
continue to think about what you can
bring to the table as a person of
integrity and dignity
and treat your wife with respect
regardless of how this thing plays out
she's still the mother of your kids i
hate that man
ugh all right let's go to sharon in
atlanta sharon what is going on how are
we doing
hey dr john uh thank you so much it is
an absolute pleasure
just to even talk to you i'm so excited
it's a pleasure to talk to you
how how can i help yeah okay so
i actually um had coveted starting on
christmas day
and i'm still recovering merry christmas
right
i know and what a way to start the new
year um
but yeah so i actually uh you know just
went through like
like on a scale of one to ten it was
literally a twelve like that's how bad
it was
and i never get sick but i'm just like
mentally and physically just so
exhausted
um because it was just so draining and
you know just being stuck in a room the
whole for two weeks
and you know you have you have all these
goals in mind like
you start you want to start the new year
with all these goals and you have plans
and
i feel like everything got kind of put
on hold so like
just kind of asking what your opinion is
like what you think how do i how could i
get myself like back on track just to
get back to kind of normal almost like
dr kovacs
yeah man you just gave me like 10
different shows with the material just
here
all right so number one um you didn't
slightly get derailed
your whole 2021 got blown up before it
started right
you're that kid i don't know if you you
weren't in cub scouts but they have
like the pinewood derby where they make
these fancy cars and they all get a line
on these
ramp and they let them go yours is the
one kid
that got stuck right when they dropped
it and all the other kids went down and
looked all smooth and pretty
and yours just your car sucked it just
got stuck there right
it went nowhere yeah and so there's
number one you got to be honest about
what happened
you got blowed up before you even got to
go up
i'm gonna i'm gonna trademark that
that's probably the smartest rap
kind of thing i said today you got
blowed up before you got to go up
um number two how honest do you want me
to be with you
because i you you sharon sound like a
really kind person
like a lovely human and i can play
high level or i can be super blunt and
jocko
will nick with you i can just be direct
which one i i would like for you to be
as honest as possible
i mean because it's just because like
i'm a very like social person
and and i've i've been out of work since
then i'm a flight attendant so it's just
it's just been so hard because i've been
in my bubble this whole time just
getting out you know even
socializing i got to learn to it's just
been
weird i just feel like i'm in a weird
place in life right now and
yes yes just exhausted okay so
here's i'm going to walk you through
real fast everything in a nutshell and i
want you to
just hold your breath while i do it okay
okay
ready i'm ready almost a year
we'll say nine to ten months of varying
stories between if you get this you're
going to be dead it's not a big deal
what's going to happen
and you're a flight attendant so am i
going to get laid off am i going to keep
my job what are we going to do
oh i've got to be on this plane they're
making me fly with all these people
we're all going to get sick we're all
going to die
oh my gosh and i love my friend but well
i kissed that boy he's probably got it
he's probably gonna die
every sniffle for the last nine months
um
you thought ah this is it this is death
right
and then yeah i want to hang out with
people it's not that big a deal
we're in atlanta it's not even in the
south so they say so we're all good in
atlanta
and then it's to get it on
freaking christmas right and then you
start thinking backwards
to all the people i was around did i
hurt somebody else because that's the
other thing right it's not only
i i might have it and be hurting other
people not even mean to but someone else
is gonna get sick and die because of me
and
and then it goes over and over and i
blew up my family's christmas plans and
my friends plans and what about 2021 i
got this new journal with all these
freaking ribbons in it that was going to
help me on my day planner journal and
month and goals and
and it all just blows up and you are
super super sick
all by yourself in a bed on christmas
day
and so there's one word for that and
it's just called trauma
okay and there's so many
influencers on the instagrams being like
dude i had it for 24 hours it was no big
deal
or there's newscasters being like
everyone should die right
the reality is for some people it's not
a big deal and for others it is the
scariest
terrifying thing i've got friends at
work i've got friends in my family i've
got i've got friends in my family i got
family members
i've had people who have had it not the
bad i've had people that were terrified
right it is what it is it was definitely
scary you got real sk
right there you go and you probably like
my idiot itself you probably went to the
internet to see what i could do and what
would happen and then they just
really fan the flame of joy right
because what else you're gonna do when
you're stuck in a room by yourself
right and i never go ahead go ahead
um i'm never go and that's another thing
like i never get sick so that's why i
think it like really hit me hard
because like i actually had to go to the
doctor twice and i was so
sick like i i didn't think i honestly
did not think i was gonna make it
because my breathing was so bad
and like it was it just hit me like oh
my gosh this is real
and then you start thinking oh i don't
ever get sick but i did this time i'm
gonna be one of the ones and right
so all i like to say is your brain is
trying to do
the best it can to take care of you
and your year got blown up at the end
and at the beginning
the one the one holiday that you've had
since you were a little girl that
everyone just goes ah
that got blown up your work got blown up
your health got blown up
everything just blew up and so what i
want you to do and this is gonna sound
ridiculous
just go with me on it okay i want you to
hold some sort of miniature funeral
for what was gonna be okay and you can
be as funny about this you can get a
glass of wine get some friends on zoom
and y'all can be silly about it or you
can be
teary and weepy about it okay but i want
you just to be honest about i want you
to have a
a moment a ceremony a a moment of just
checking and pause where you're gonna
grieve
what just happened because it sucks
right yeah and it's not just that you
got covered and that's really really
sick
it's all of it all the scary all of the
year it all culminated and it all just
goes
boom right there on your body right and
then
you had to sit for two weeks alone sick
alone there's nothing worse than being
alone there's nothing worse than being
sick alone
right with just screens and sleep and
screens and a doctor and then almost
death and then right so it's just on and
on and
then you have to let this fantasy of
what 2021 was gonna be go
and then i'm gonna give you some joy
okay
okay there is a wonderful saying by the
the great
um they're the great meditating gurus
but that every breath is a chance to
start over
right every breath is a chance to start
over
and so i don't want to undermine what
just happened it's a big deal
and your body's wrecked because of it
and that means your heart and your soul
and your spirit's wrecked of it
hold the funeral acknowledge what was
acknowledge what blew up in your face
and then say it's tuesday january
whatever
i'm starting today right
now i'm gonna start 2021 however late we
are and hey after what happened the last
few weeks with the
all the stupid stuff going on in the
country with politics and all that
why not start late right that's true
so good you're beating the system here
so way to go
so you now have a level of empathy
for the scared people that you're gonna
be walking up and down the aisle with
on your in your work you're going to
have a
new level of empathy for folks that you
work with who haven't got it yet who are
terrified they're going to get it
you have a new level of empathy of what
it's like to be just freaking alone
you have a new level of empathy for what
um getting sick looks like
the difference between media coverage
right what's real and what's not
you now have an insight to that you
didn't have before would you want it do
you want to experience that no but you
have it now
right and that is a firm
beautiful foundation of empathy love
compassion
and now there's no stopping me now you
had it now you had it now it's on 2021
right now sharon from atlanta game on
sister
i'm gonna go get it yeah right yeah and
now you can do whatever you want
and you can that i love yeah i actually
that
just you just picture like i just
pictured like a whole
sunshine after you said that that's what
it is i didn't even look at it that way
like you know yeah definitely because
there's other people that are probably
there
are going through especially after
holidays okay don't do that okay share
it
share it don't do that don't compare
your situation to somebody else well at
least i didn't have that
right don't do that your grief is your
grief is your grief you get to own it it
sucked it was
if you got coveted for 48 hours and you
just had weird weird weird boogers
right and rocket diarrhea and that's it
and you have a friend who went to the
hospital and she was put on a ventilator
for four days before she got to come
home
both of you have a right to your hurt
okay
don't minimize it don't minimize it and
don't be like well you're right other
people
in other countries have food don't do
that that's why i want you to hold a
ceremony for what happened to you
okay okay hold it it was what it was
and then yes the sun comes up and it may
not come up on the landscape we wanted
it may not come up in the home that we
wanted it may not come up in the
in the at the school we wanted to be yet
it may not come up with the guy that we
thought we were going to be whatever the
thing is
but the sun always comes up it always
comes up
and then we go back to what the ancient
meditators would say is
every breath has a chance to start over
and i've been guilty guilty of like man
it's
it's may i've blown this year i can't
wait till till new year's right i'm
going to start over new york that's so
stupid i blew a whole year man
so all you lost was three weeks that's
man you were in it
to win it by the way can i um
sharon i wanna thank you for that call
here's what i want you to do after your
funeral i want you to shoot me a note
back and i'm going to read what your
note is
after you have this miniature funeral
again it can be funny it can be serious
i want you to let that go the fantasy of
2021 is going to be
pop rocks and fireworks and flowers and
it's not it sucked i got covered i was
stuck in bed i almost died
but now the sun's coming up and what are
we going to make of it right and then i
want to hear what you're going to do i
want to hear what you're going to write
down here's the person i'm going to be
in 2021
more empathetic more loving more looking
people in the eye and saying i see you
for the first time that's going to be
awesome um and then here's
man this gets me a little bit ranty and
i won't because
i want to wrap the show up here but you
guys
i i talk a lot about um you got to match
your pictures with words
right we often use the same words and we
mean different things
covet is a great example about how
different
disciplines use the same words
and then they run off into the woods
with totally different meanings
if you guys remember back in february or
march of last year when this thing
started making its way around the world
um i was in manhattan when they closed
broadway
i was on broadway with my friend ken
coleman we were walking down broadway
when they walked out and said broadway's
canceled
and we both looked at each other like
that sounds super great
and they said cancelled until further
notice and
no one had ever heard of anything like
that ever happening so we were downtown
new york when this thing started
when it became started falling like a
bunch of dominoes
and there were some modeling experts
some epidemiologists and modeling folks
who
made some predictions early on at
university science labs and
they in again labs some of you guys
think of labs with beakers
some labs have people in them some labs
have computers in them so i'm using the
word liberty
liberally here um liberally is that
that's right yep yeah um
and they said hey we think 13 14 million
people are going to die or whatever
wild number it was so here's the thing
in science when they say
i think this for scientists that means
game on
because the whole practice of science is
based on iron sharpens iron peer review
oh yeah
i am going to reject your null
hypothesis i'm going to go
try to find out where you're wrong i'm
going to look in the gap look in the gap
look in the gap
and then shortly a few weeks later it
had been revised down
we think seven million people so those
folks took those new models new
information new data and they're making
new models the new models and they're
they're reducing reducing they're
getting better and better and better
so science has a built-in mechanism when
it's honest with itself
for i think this here's my hypothesis
here's what i think is going to happen
and then all other scientists in that
area in that field or in peripheral
fields
they go to war dude it is on and it's
this beautiful
refining process to try to get to truth
right but you know who doesn't have a
refining process
politicians in the media because they
all walked out the next day and said 14
million people are gonna die
and they have no ability because of ego
because of narrow-minded thinking
short-term thinking they have no way to
go back and say
oh you know what the best information we
had last week was 14 million people
the the latest data tells us it's going
to be 10 million that's a great news
everybody we're going to keep
learning the best we can doing what we
have in our pockets right now but
the number's getting smaller it's still
way way way way too big but
they can't do that they have to look at
each other and start saying well you
lied well you lied well you're stupid
science is dumb
and it's this this crosstalk that
happens in marriages it happens in
families it happens in businesses
happens in schools
where people are using the same language
and they're using it to mean different
things
god almighty if politicians could say
these magic words i'm sorry i learned
new information
i'm changing i'm changing what i said
the other day and i'm going this way and
if we all
cheered those people you know why
because that's wisdom
the ability to say oh dude i got new
info i got new info
and now i'm wiser and i'm going to
restate something that i said earlier
i'm going to say something differently i
changed my mind and we all cheered for
them
ah can you imagine that if the media was
able to come out on a tuesday after
making a big report on monday and be
like hey we got that one wrong
whoopsie do our bad we got new
information we screwed that up
here's the new thing oh we didn't even
screw it up we just tried our best with
what we had
and we got we got new information
all i had to say is say the words i'm
sorry be people of wisdom be people that
said man i got new info
all right so as we wrap up the show i
talk on that all day long
oh man all right so i'm in it now
everybody i asked another young person
in the office
i need the best song of 2021 no i said
the best song ever
it happened to be the best song of 22 a
song that has existed since 2021 started
that should have been clue number one
so it's off a record that was recently
released
it's called anyone by justin bieber and
it goes like this
dance with me under the diamonds says
justin sleep with me
see me see me like stop you right there
no justin bieber
no we're just gonna go and wrap it's a
good tune man
i listen to it it's good no no they're
waving me off i'm a fan
of his older albums but we're gonna
we're gonna go ahead and wrap this here
you can read two more lines we'll see
how it goes
[Music]
if it's not you it's not anyone not
anyone i tried justin
this has been the dr john dolone show